The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
DOUG LAUFFENBURGER:
So we shall start.
I haven't had the pleasure
of meeting most of you.
I'm Doug Lauffenburger.
I'm gratefully invited for
a guest presentation here.
So I'll definitely enjoy it.
There should be plenty of time.
I'm not racing through
a lot of material,
so feel free to interrupt
me with questions.
And of course I'll try
to respond as best I can.
OK.
Who has looked at the
background materials that
were posted on the web a
long time ago, last night?
Who already will admit
to having looked at it?
Good.
All right.
I guess that means
I should do this
because otherwise if
you've read it already then
there'd be no point, right?
OK.
Well, where we are
in your semester--
you're learning a lot of things
across the whole spectrum
of computational
systems biology.
I hope I'll add
something in here.
It's actually a
very specific topic.
We talk about modeling of
cell signaling networks,
and in particular, one approach
is worth going through today
and that's the logic
modeling framework.
So I'll give you a little bit
of a conceptual background
for the first 10 or 15 minutes.
Then we'll launch into
the particular example
that was in the main paper.
And a little side light
with an application of it
to a particular cancer problem.
And then that should take
us pretty much to the end.
OK.
The biological topic here
is cell signaling, primarily
mammalian cells.
Certainly applicable
to microbial cells
in a simpler sense.
So just to place the context,
in mammalian cell biology,
I'm a bio-engineer and a cell
biologist at the same time.
We're very interested in what
controls the cell behavior,
their phenotypic response.
We know that it's
in fact controlled
by what it sees in their
environment, growth
factors, hormones, extracellular
matrix, mechanical forces,
cell-cell contacts.
A variety of queues
in the environment
and the way these govern
phenotype or control phenotype
is that they influence,
they regulate
what I would call the
execution processes.
The crucial execution processes
such as gene expression,
transcription, and
translation are
governed by
extracellular factors.
Metabolism, synthesis
of new molecules,
cytoskeleton, motors,
forced generation.
These things all
carry out phenotype
governed by the extracellular
stimuli or cues.
And it happens via these
biochemical signaling
pathways that are activated
primarily by cell surface
receptors in the plasmid
membrane-- cascades
of biochemical reactions,
mostly enzymatic.
Some protein-protein
docking, mostly
post-translational
modifications.
Kinase phosphate reactions
adding and taking off
phosphate groups that change
protein activities at locations
and so forth.
It could be other types of
post-translation modifications.
It could be second messengers,
calcium, ATP aces and so forth.
So, the extracellular--
now my battery's dead.
That's not good.
Oh, there we go.
Extracellular stimuli,
generate the signals.
They regulate gene expression,
metabolism, cytoskeleton.
They carry out phenotype.
OK.
So we want to learn about cell
signaling network operations.
There's actually multiple
pathways involved.
We really need to
study many of them
in concert to understand
what the cells are doing.
And a big question is,
what kind of information
do we need to study this?
And on the end, we'd
be interested in how
phenotypic behavior does arise
from variations and mutations
in the genomic content of cells.
But that genomic content,
of course, is not modified,
but its effects are
influenced by what's
the environment to these
extracellular cues,
log ins and so forth.
So they influence what
message is expressed.
From that message
they influence what's
actually translated
into protein.
From those proteins
they influence
the post-translational
modifications
and what the proteins
are actually doing.
And so, in the
end, the phenotype
is carried out by these
protein operations.
And the question
is, what information
level that we might
want to study.
And of course you would
love to have the information
content at all levels--
genomic information,
transcriptional information,
translational information,
post-translational information.
So integrating all those
different data levels
can be extremely valuable.
In terms of the models I'm
going to talk about today,
they've essentially
been living at the level
of protein activities in
these signaling pathways.
OK.
That will be the
kind of data sets
you'll see that will be analyzed
with respect to the models.
Obviously, they arise from
these underlying mechanisms
that, as influenced by
the environmental context,
altering the signaling
protein activities.
OK.
And what's very
interesting and there's
going to be more and more
progress in the coming years
is relating what's in the
genomic information-- mutations
and variations to what's
happening at the protein level.
And some of the other
instructors in this class
are really some of
the world's experts
in figuring out how to do this.
I'd like to just
show this example
as a motivation for
this kind of approach.
And that is if you do gene
sequencing of many patient
tumors-- in this
case, I believe this
was a paper on
pancreatic tumors.
This has been shown for pretty
much every other type of tumor
since then.
In any given patient tumor,
each one of these bars,
there's dozens of
mutations in each tumor.
And a variety of
types-- deletions,
amplifications mutations
and by and large, they're
all different.
There's very few
mutations themselves
that really carry over to
a substantial proportion
of one patient's
tumor to another.
There's some special cases
that are fairly pervasive,
but the predominant of these
dozens and dozens of mutations
and variations are
different from one patient
to another, and even
in the same patient.
So what's emerging
as a productive way
to think about this-- How
do all these different types
of mutations and
specific mutations
actually lead to classes
of similar pathologies?
And that is they
tend to reside in
what can be identified
as pathways-- circuits,
machines, things that
are actually carrying out
function at the protein level.
So for instance-- I'm
losing this again.
For these pancreatic
cancers on this wheel
are about a dozen different
signaling pathways
and self-cycle control
pathways and apoptosis
controlled pathways.
And if you look at any
individual patient tumors,
like this green one or this red
one-- two different patients.
If you actually look at the
mutations at the genomic level,
they're entirely different
in the green patient
tumor versus the
red patient tumor.
So if you're just trying
to match gene mutation
to pancreatic cancer,
these two patients
would look entirely different.
But, it turns out, that you
can line up their mutations
into the same
pathways and say, OK,
the red tumor and
the green tumor
both have mutations that
affect the TGF beta pathway.
They're different
mutations, but they've just
regulated that pathway.
And similarly, you can
do that with pretty much
all of the other mutations.
That these tumors
have been dysregulated
in terms of particular pathways.
But patient to
patient to patient,
it's happened by different
genomic gene sequence
mutations.
So that the ability to
look at these protein
level pathways is
a way of making
really good productive sense
of the gene sequencing data.
So there's lots of labs trying
to go from gene sequence
up to pathway modulation.
In our case, we're not
going to show you that here.
We're going to say,
this is a motivation
for starting at
the protein level.
And I'd like to show
this picture too.
Number one because it's
such an anachronism.
This is a circuit board from
decades and decades and decades
ago that none of
you would recognize.
But, in the molecular biology
world, this kind of a picture,
and in its modern form is viewed
as a very appealing metaphor
for how to think
about these signaling
pathways and signaling networks
that take the extracellular
information and turn it into
governance of transcription,
metabolism, cytoskeleton,
and phenotype.
So, just this
metaphor of circuitry,
where in white, the
extracellular ligands,
growth factors are
somehow wired to the blue.
The cell surface receptors,
or B for instance--
they're wired too.
Kinases and other
signaling proteins--
they're wired to transcription
factors, self-cycle control
regulators,
apoptosis regulators.
So these very famous folks
in cancer biology say,
what you've got to understand
is, these signalling networks
as circuitry.
And if the circuitry is
dysregulated somehow,
the wiring is different,
then that's what's
underlying malignant behavior.
So, this is really
beautiful but it's
pretty much useless, right.
Because there's no prediction or
calculation or even hypothesis
generation one can do
from a picture like this.
Yes, it's circuitry, but
what do I do with it?
So, what I want
to show you today
are efforts to
turn them into what
I would call an actionable
model, a computable model.
Yes, it looks kind
of like circuitry,
but in fact you would know
how to do a calculation that
would fit it to data
and predict new data.
And then you have, in fact, a
model rather than a metaphor.
That's the idea.
So, one question is, if
you want to turn that
into a formal mathematical
framework for circuitry
that you can calculate--
what kind of mathematics
might you use?
And in this class
you're learning
a whole spectrum of things.
And one can think
about it on one hand,
if we knew all of
those components
and how they interacted, and
could estimate rate constance
and so forth, we could
write differential equations
for maybe the dozens and dozens
of components and interactions
and predict how they would
play out dynamically with time.
For most systems with
the complexity that's
really controlling cell
biology, at this point in time,
this is almost impossible.
There's only rare
cases where enough
is known about
signaling biochemistry
to really write
down differential
equations for what's going on.
At the other extreme,
of course, is the type
of mathematics one gets out
of very, very large data sets,
sequencing data sets,
transcriptional, and so forth.
More informatics
type of analysis,
where it has to do
with multivariate
regression and clustering,
mutual information.
And what we've been working on
is someplace up in the middle
where you don't have enough
mechanistic prior knowledge
to write this formal
of physics, and yet
takes you someplace beyond
statistical associations.
And this is one
of the areas that
might be worth your
learning in this class.
OK, this is really the same
set of computational methods,
just like it's cast in a
little bit different form that
delineates competition
modeling, really
into two kinds of classes.
What's traditionally appreciated
in most fields of engineering
and physics are
differential equations
that are very theory driven.
You have a theory.
You have prior knowledge
for what's happening.
You're writing down the
components involved,
you're writing down
how they interact.
And typically,
algebraic equations
for those differential
equations describe your theory,
describe your prior knowledge.
And now it's formalized and
you estimate rate constants
and so forth.
Another whole class
of information
is data driven, in
which, you really
don't have a good theory
about what components matter
and how they interact.
And so you start with
data sets and from it
you do classification or
typologies or associations
with different types of
mathematics that at least try
to make sense and get hypotheses
out of these large data
sets, where you don't
have any theory.
One reason that logic
modeling appeals to me,
is that it actually
can be applied
in either the theory driven
or the data driven mode.
You can say, I know
nothing about my system.
I just generate large data sets
of signaling network activities
induced by different
stimuli, but I'm
going to try to fit a
logic model to it that
says how the different
components influencing
each other in a logic way.
Or, you could say,
well, I know something.
I have some prior knowledge.
I may have interact ohms the say
what molecular components are
present in signaling networks.
And so in principle, I
kind of know who's involved
and who might be
influencing whom.
And I could write a logic model
based on that prior knowledge.
And then run calculations
and see if it actually
makes predictions about
experimental data.
So that's one nice thing.
It's a mathematical
formalism that
can either be run in data driven
mode or in theory driven mode
and go back and forth.
So that's one reason--
given one lecture to offer,
I've decided to offer
it on this topic.
All right, with me so far?
Any questions?
Philosophy?
OK.
So, what we're
going to do today is
almost take a
hybrid of these two.
We're going to say, what
prior knowledge do we have,
and then recognize that
it's really not enough.
And so how do we now integrate
that with empirical data
to now come up with
logic modeling that,
in fact, is actionable
and computable?
OK.
So what kind of prior
knowledge do we have?
Let's say we wanted to have
a logic model for what's
in these signaling networks
down stream of growth factor
receptors, or hormone receptors,
or things like that, that then
govern gene expression,
metabolism and so forth.
What prior knowledge do we have?
And you folks
probably have already
seen some of this in the class.
There's all kinds of
databases of stuff.
What's in those databases
that might be relevant here?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] that the
protein-protein interactions--
if you switch proteins, they
interact with each other,
but maybe not necessarily
what pathways they're in.
DOUG LAUFFENBURGER: OK, good.
And have you seen
databases like that?
AUDIENCE: Several of
them have come up.
DOUG LAUFFENBURGER: OK.
Are you the only
one who's seen them?
Or is there anybody
else that kind
of noticed them in passing too?
OK, good.
Second, third,
fourth, all right.
That's a critical mass
if I ever saw one.
OK.
So, I'm just going
to allude to those.
So there are pathway databases.
And this is actually an
old slide of a few years
ago, so I'm sure the
numbers are all different.
And, in fact, there's new ones.
I just haven't taken
to updating the slide.
But we'll, based on literature,
take certain numbers
of gene products, a
few hundred of them,
and organize them into pathways
based on biological knowledge.
There's other databases that
are more interactomes, usually
based on other kinds of
experimental data-- yeast II
hybrid, mass spectrometry,
literature curation,
that also tries to say who's
physically interacting.
So these node-- these pathway
databases don't necessarily
say, somebody's
physically interacting,
they say somebody might
be upstream and downstream
and so forth.
And then they
interactome databases
say, component a
and component b,
there's some evidence that they
have a physical association
someplace along the way.
So these are two
complementary types
of databases that, in
fact, can be put together.
OK.
So an interesting
thing about these--
there's a number
of these databases.
And so in principle
you could say, well
if I want then to start-- if
I want to generate a logic
model for signaling
networks, all
I have to do is take
what's in the database
and say what pathways
are there and what's
known with their
interactions, and now I've
got a starting point.
You know, I can
actually draw a graph
with lots of molecular nodes and
lots of molecular interactions.
So, you can do that.
And so you can choose
one of these databases
and say I'm going
to draw a graph that
has what's believed to be
true about nodes and pathways
and interactions and
signaling networks.
But then you choose a different
database and another database.
And you'll actually get
different information.
OK.
We actually did a study
on this-- I probably
should have given you the
citation of that-- that
said if you look at six or
seven of these databases,
they are not coincident.
They have a very
small intersections.
Most of their information
is non-redundant.
And so you could try
to put it all together.
And we did this,
again, in this paper
that I'm not giving
you a citation for.
And so here's a number of
nodes and signaling pathways
downstream of receptors.
And all the colored
nodes are those
in which they appear in
only one of these-- one, two
three, four, five,
six databases.
So if something's colored
green, it's only in GeneGo
and it's not in
any of the others.
If something's
colored purple, it's
in PANTHER and
none of the others.
OK.
If they're gray-- some
of these gray ones,
they're in at least two.
But out of these six, there's
an exceedingly small number
of nodes interactions that
are in all six databases.
Which was a real surprise
to us when we did this.
So what this means
is, if you want
to start with some
prior knowledge graph
that you're now going to fit
a logic model to by mapping it
against data, you first
even have the choice, well,
what am I going to start with?
What is my prior knowledge?
There;s not really
consensus prior knowledge.
So you can start with six
different interaction graphs.
Or you could try to
put them all together
and get a consensus graph.
So you have all these choices.
And right now, it's
not as if is there's
detailed analysis of what
the best choice would
be for your starting point.
But I want to stress that,
with respect to our approach,
this is a starting
point because one
of the issues with the
database information
is that it's typically
very diverse with respect
to contact.
What cell type did this
information come from?
What treatment conditions
did it come from?
If there's different cell
types, different species,
different mutations.
So if I see interactions or
if I don't see interactions,
are they in conflict?
Or they're just-- this
one was in a lymphocyte,
this one was in a
hypatocye, this one
was in a cardiac myocyte, and
they're actually different.
OK, so if I had a cell
type specific database,
or pulled that information
out, that would be good.
It would be a smaller
number of things.
But then under what
treatment conditions?
Because remember I said starting
with the genomic content, what
you actually see in terms
of molecular interactions
will be very strongly
affected by what
matrix were the
cells growing on?
Or was this in vivo?
Was this in a multicellular
culture situation?
So, that's why this
is a starting point
and can't really
be used to describe
any particular experimental
situation with much confidence.
The other thing--
and this is what
I've been trying to
emphasize from the start-- is
that there's no calculation
you can do on this.
There's a group of
folks in this field who
propose some ideas that I
think are very intriguing,
but which, at least
to me personally,
there's not that
much evidence for.
And that is, that there's
topological characteristics
of these graphs, that then
tell you what's important.
So if I have a
node that's somehow
connected to more
other nodes, that
is going to be a
more important node,
and might be associated with the
disease, versus a node that's
connected to fewer.
OK.
Some of these are very, very
appealing ideas conceptually.
If you actually look for
the experimental evidence
that they're valid
notions, it's very thin.
But, that's where some
folks would claim,
oh, you can do predictions
on the hypotheses based
on these graphs because
there are these graph theory
characteristics
that somehow might
be biologically meaningful.
OK.
But I'd say, jury's out on
whether, in fact, any of that
is true.
So, our view is-- OK, this
is a good starting point,
but in fact, needs to be
mapped to empirical data
in order to gain confidence
about calculations you can do.
So that's the goal of
this kind of approach,
is to say, let's
stipulate that we start
with some prior
knowledge scaffold.
This particular one is from
the Ingenuity database.
You could get one from
any other database.
You could get a consensus one
from three or four if you want.
And so it has, up here,
extracellular stimuli,
growth factors, cytokines.
They're connected in their
interactome II receptors.
They're connected to scaffolding
proteins and signaling proteins
and kinases and so forth.
They're connected to
transcription factors,
metabolic enzymes.
So you can draw this graph.
Say this might be what's
going on in my cell.
And then what we'd like
to do is to turn this
into a formal logic
framework that's
capable of then fitting
experimental data,
predicting new
and giving you a chance
at biological hypothesis
and testing.
All right, so
conceptually you get it?
Two aspects-- some kind of
starting prior knowledge,
that's kind of a scaffold,
a graph, for your network.
And now you're going to turn it
into a computable logic model
by mapping it against
empirical data.
So, merely what it takes is
the kind of conceptual diagram
you see in any cell biology
paper, any signaling paper,
that says, well, a and b
both influence e positively,
and b influences f negatively,
and c influences f positively.
Then there's a
feedback from g to a.
That's inhibitory.
You can draw those.
But now, how do you turn it
into a computable algorithm?
So, what I'm going to spend
most of the day on is,
just conversion of
this to a Boolean logic
model that any one of these
interactions is and-- a and b
being active makes e active.
c being active, but
b not being active,
allows f to be
active, and so forth.
You turn these into
formal logic statements
that you can compute on.
At the very end,
if we have time,
I'll show how to relax this from
a Boolean framework that's just
on off, to something that
can be more quantitative.
All right.
So that's the notion.
Now what I'm going to do
for the rest of the time
is go through the specific
example paper that says, OK,
how do we in fact do this?
What is a way to
accomplish this?
So now let's go back
to a biological problem
where there's going to be
empirical, experimental data
that we're now going
to map against one
of these prior knowledge
interactome graphs.
This particular study-- this was
done with Peter Sorger, who's
now at Harvard Medical School--
had to do with liver cells.
Liver cancer-- you'll see
some application of that
at the end-- that says we
have liver cell hepatocytes.
And we want to know how they
respond to different growth
factors, in cytokines
in their environment.
How that'll change their
proliferation or death?
Or the inflammatory
cytokines that they produce.
And we'd like to take-- this is
just a pictorial diagram that
could be in any
cell biology paper,
and make this calculable.
So we could say what's
different from a primary normal
hepatocyte liver cell
that's not cancerous?
It might have a signaling logic.
But if then we compare
the signaling logic
to a liver tumor cell type, or
four different liver tumor cell
types, what's different?
If we can find some logic that's
different for the tumor cell
lines versus the normal primary
lines-- some logic from here
to there or to there-- that now
tells you biologically, where
the differences
might be that have
arisen from the
genetic mutations.
And where good drug
targets might be,
or predictions if
I intervene here,
if there's no difference in
that logic, between normal
and tumor, well then that
won't have any effect.
I want to look for
the places where
there is a difference
in the signaling logic.
And that would be a
better drug target.
OK, so the measurements
are made in
across 17 of these different
signaling molecules
here, pretty much
all by measurement
of a phosphorylation state.
So if you've done cell
biology or biochemistry--
in these signaling
pathways, many
of the activities in
these kinds of pathways
that regulate this
kind of cell behavior
are kinases that end up
affecting transcription factor
activities and so forth.
And it's the
phosphorylation state
of any these proteins
that matters.
If a phosphate is on some
particular amino acid,
the enzyme might be active.
If it's not there it might
be inactive and so forth.
So, just measurement of
phosphorylation states
of 17 different proteins
in these pathways
distributed across
multiple pathways.
I've made these measurements on
five different cell types, four
tumor cell types,
and the primaries
in order to try to see what's
different between primary
and tumor.
And then what might be
different, patient to patient.
In response to seven different
extracellular stimuli,
some of them growth
factors, some of them
cytokines, some of them actually
bacterial metabolic products.
We all know about the effects
of microbiome these days.
And, to further
populate a database that
might be capable
of helping validate
a model, a number of seven,
in fact-- intercellular
inhibitors.
A small molecule,
these things in black.
One that might
inhibit this kinase.
One might inhibit that kinase.
So now if you add all
those inhibitors too,
then you start to change
the network activities
and the downstream behavior.
So that's how
extensive the data is.
And this is actually for a
few different time points.
So the data looks
something like this.
Let's focus on the
one on the left.
This is just the primary,
normal, human cells.
It came from a liver donor.
OK.
Each row is one of the
17 different signals,
essentially measurement
of the phosphorylation
state of Akt or CREB
or P52 of staph 3.
OK?
So measurements of
its phosphorylation
state that has something to do
with its signaling activity.
Each of the big columns are the
seven different treatments--
the different growth factors
and cytokines and so forth.
And the control.
No stimulation.
And within each one
of these treatments,
in each one of these
stimuli, then there's
seven different
inhibitors that were
used for the different pathways.
So seven stimuli by seven
inhibitors plus controls.
And then three
different time points.
Sort of zero, 30
minutes, and three hours.
So the data looks
something like this.
If there's really no change,
due to the stimulation
or the inhibitor, you'll
see something in gray.
So in these gray bars,
there was already
phosphorylation of this
transcription factor
[INAUDIBLE] and it didn't really
change under most treatments.
If it was yellow,
what it meant was,
whatever the treatment was,
you got a quick activation
of that signal and
then it went away.
If it's late-- purple, then it
didn't happen in the first half
hour, but it started to
show up a few hours later.
And if it's green it showed
up in the first half hour
and it stayed sustained.
So that's what the color means.
But this is the real
experimental data.
And over here on the right is
one of the tumor cell lines.
And you can just
see by inspection,
it's different, right.
The colors here are different
from the colors there.
All the same treatments,
stimuli inhibitors.
The colors are very different.
You know, therefore that
the signaling activities
are very different.
OK.
Just by visual inspection.
So what we're going to try
to do is build a logic model
for this.
A logic model for this.
Compare them and say, oh where
are the key differences in how
the signaling pathways
are getting activated?
Downstream of the same stimuli.
So, we start with
our prior knowledge.
This is from the Ingenuity
database, which actually
happened to be missing,
even basic information
about insulin signaling.
So we just added
our own information
about what the
insulin receptor does.
It's kind of hard to believe.
This is a database that
cost a lot of money
and they didn't have
really much information
about insulin
receptor signaling.
Very strange.
So, downstream of
our seven stimuli,
down to the transcription
factors of interest,
there are about 82 molecular
nodes and a hundred some edges
that you'd pull out of
the Ingenuity database.
So here's our starting guess
at what this looks like.
There's no logic in here, but
this is just, potentially,
the things that the
logic might operate on,
downstream of stimuli, and
when inhibited, and so forth.
All right.
So here's the process.
This was the actual
algorithmic process
that I'll walk you through.
On the left-hand side
is the computer part.
It said, OK, from the
Ingenuity database,
we had this prior
knowledge about who
was upstream, downstream,
who affected whom.
We strip this down
some, because in terms
of the measurements
on the perturbations,
there are some of the nodes
that you just would not
be able to see any
measurable difference.
OK, there was no stimulus
upstream, or no perturbation.
And it was not
measured so you really
wouldn't be able to tell
if it changed or not.
So you just take those out.
Of everything remaining, now
you don't know the logic.
You know the potential.
And so you say, well, of all
the nodes and interactions
remaining, I could have AND
gates, I could have OR gates,
you could have NOTS.
And you say, OK, in
principle, I could have,
then, many, many, many,
many, many different logic
models that could work.
So how do I know which one?
Well now you skip
over to the other side
and say, well, but we have
all this experimental data.
We have the data from
all the different stimuli
and all the different inhibitors
for any given cell type.
And so, we have that data under
all these different conditions.
And what we're
going to do is just
run hundreds or thousands of
these potentially appropriate
models.
Compare them to the data of
whether any given node is
activated or not, activated
under treatment conditions,
stimuli inhibitors.
And we'll calculate the air.
How good was any
one of those models
at actually matching those data?
Simple as that.
And then it's a
matter of finding
what are the best fit ones
from the best fit ones.
Could you improve them and
make them fit even better?
And in the end, how did you go
from an initial prior knowledge
scaffold to something that, in
fact, fit the data really well,
from which you could
make new predictions.
OK.
So you get the approach here?
All right, good.
Now, in terms of figuring
out how well any given
model matches the data and how
to go through model selection,
there's a myriad of
different approaches to this.
And I'm not claiming
that what we did
was the absolute best approach.
There's alternatives to
it that one could consider
and then perhaps could
work even better.
If you read the paper,
you'll read the reasons
for these choices.
OK.
So I'll let you do that.
The way the model
quality was calculated
was to have an
objective function that
said we want to minimize
some number, theta.
And how do we calculate theta?
Well, first of all, for
whatever that model is,
we're going to fit-- whether
the model says some nodes
should be on or
off, one or zero.
And we're going to compare
it to the experimental data.
Now the experimental
data, I need to emphasize,
isn't one or zero,
it's normalized
to go between one and zero.
But the actual measurement
might be 0.7 or 0.25.
OK, so you're going to have
error against the Boolean model
even if all the edges are
absolutely correct you'll
still going to get some
quantitative error.
So you calculate that.
The Boolean model
says zero or one.
The experimental
data says 0.250, 0.7.
And you say, OK,
I'll calculate that.
But then you might
think, all right, well,
somehow I've got to penalize
bigger models with more
nodes and more edges because
surely the more nodes and edges
I put in, I could
capture more of the data.
And I don't want to make
the model infinitely large
just to get the best fit.
So I need to penalize that.
Turns out it's not true, but
nonetheless it's worth doing.
So, you take a parameter
that's the size of the model.
It's basically just
the number of nodes.
The more nodes in
it, the more you
would be suspicious of
the model for just fitting
because it has too
many components.
And you multiply that size by
a penalty parameter, alpha.
So you have a bad
objective function
if there's a lot of
error with the data,
or if your model's too big.
A better model would be, better
fit to the data and smaller.
That's the calculation.
OK.
And in the end-- and I'm going
to show you how we did this.
And I think the field is
now really believing this.
That what you're not after
is a single best fit model.
That one single model that gives
you the very smallest data.
Because honestly,
within the uncertainty
of the experimental
data-- OK, there's
a substantial number
of models that
could fit the data
within that noise.
So if you demanded
the single best one,
you say, well, but
these other 50 actually
fit it almost as good and within
the uncertainty of the data.
How can you really reject them?
And you can't.
So in the end, what's
being striven for in most
of the field is a
family of models.
And then you see
what the consensus
is and the differences
within that family.
The particular algorithm
for generating and running
through different
potential models--
because you just
can't exhaustively
sample all of them.
OK, these networks are so large,
that you can't exhaustively
test all possibilities of
all their logic and so forth.
It's really prohibitive.
So there's many different
ways you can go about it.
This particular method
maybe you've already
learned this in class
for other applications
as a genetic algorithm.
So you start with
some population.
You start with your
Ingenuity scaffold
and then you randomly remove
or take edges and things
like that.
So that if you've
got a whole family,
that's slightly different.
For each one of them you
evaluate the objective function
against the data.
And you get some of those that
then are the most attractive.
They seem to be the best fit.
But, by no means would you
imagine they are yet optimal.
So, now you create a next
generation from this population
by the analog of genetics.
Some of the very best--
you say, OK, they're
going to survive so I'm just
going to take them as is.
Some I'm going to
mutate, I'm going
to have a probability of
mutating an edge here or there.
You can have crossover,
actually mating
between one model
and another model,
so that the daughter
model gets some
of the arcs from the mother
model and some of the arcs
from the father model.
So you just generate an
ex-population, do it again.
And once you've
reached a set of models
that fit your data
within the criteria
that you want, then you say,
this is now my population.
And these are now
my best-fit models.
So it's not exhaustive.
You can definitely find
local minimum here.
There's no question about that.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Do you always take the
best model into the next round?
Or do you--
DOUG LAUFFENBURGER: Yeah,
that's the elite survival.
If you don't
incorporate that, you
might lose the best
ones in any given round.
But this ensures you
take the best subset.
Let them go for it.
AUDIENCE: Is there
a worry that you
might get stuck in [INAUDIBLE]?
DOUG LAUFFENBURGER: Yes.
Yes, absolutely.
So now you run this with a
number of different starting
populations.
And you see if you get to
similar consensus models.
Yeah, because
absolutely, this does not
guarantee any kind
of a global minimum.
You will always get local.
So you have to condition
it on a different set
of initial populations.
OK.
Once you do this-- I'm going
to show you some results
first and then dig into some
other ways to think about it.
So it's plotted here.
This is one of the
tumor cell lines.
What's plotted here, is again,
all the rows or all the signals
that were measured.
All the big columns or
all the different stimuli,
and all the little columns
are the different inhibitors.
And I should point out, this
is only for the 30 minute data.
OK.
This isn't for the
three hour or both,
this is just the 30 minute data.
And basically where
there's green,
the model and data
fit was considered OK.
Where it's red, it's not OK.
Where it's pink it's less bad.
So by the shaded.
And the yellow
actually, the model
really couldn't
make a prediction.
Now, why that's the case
is what's showing up here
is just the initial
Ingenuity scaffold.
The very best one that
didn't add or remove any
arcs or nodes from the
Ingenuity prior knowledge.
It's that all we're
going to do is just
run the best fit Boolean
logic model we can on that.
And it wasn't very good.
It was about 45% error.
Almost half of the
nodes it got wrong.
So what that tells you if you
just take a scaffold from one
is interactive databases
and without adulterating it,
just fit the best logic
model to some data--
OK, at least in this case, and
we've done a number of others,
it actually doesn't
fit very well.
And the reasons being,
you're trying to fit this now
to a very specific
biological context.
Hepatocyte tumor
cells under these
grow factor and
cytokine treatments.
That network is
likely very different
from whatever aggregate you
got from literature curation
and so forth in a database.
There's going to be a lot of
stuff in the database that's
not applicable, because it
came from a different cell
type, a different
condition, or there just
wasn't enough experiments in
the literature for hypatocytes.
Maybe it was never
measured under treatment
with interferon gamma.
So there's data here
that the database never
had access to literature
that it had explored.
So lots of reasons.
Now when you go through the
processes we just talked about,
and in the end,
the best fit models
give you something like
less than 10% error.
So less than 10% of these
squares are red or pink.
OK, so that's the
kind of improvement
that you can take by
generating an improved model.
By adding and subtracting
arcs and nodes.
So this is what the model looks
like in the end for this tumor
cell line.
And this is a consensus model
from the 20 or so best fit.
And so the thickness
of a line is
how strong the consensus was.
The strongest would
be all 20 had it.
And the point here being,
you see some purple.
And I wish my pen wasn't
fading in and out.
If anybody has a pointer
I'll be happy to have it.
Where you see purple,
those were arcs that
weren't in the
Ingenuity database
and had to be put in to get
the data to fit this well.
And it turns out,
if you actually
go back to the literature, you
find that those purple arcs
were already described
in the literature.
It's just that they weren't
captured in that database.
Well that's green and purple.
Then you see some
blue and they were
in some of the other
tumor cell types
but now in this
particular hep G2
But you can generate a
model that works very well.
And see that it's consistent
with much of literature.
It's a more stripped down
than what's in the databases.
And there's some new
things in it, that in fact,
if you go back to the
literature you can find,
because they just were
captured in the database.
All right.
A few insights
about the analysis.
So I want to show you, here
is the objective function.
How well the model
fit and that's in red.
OK.
And in blue is the actual
fit to the experimental data.
And again, the hirer
it is the worse it is.
And the green gives you
essentially the size.
And this is plotted
against the size penalty.
And what's very interesting,
is even for very small size
penalties, almost negligible,
that the size of the model that
turns out to be best fit
is substantially smaller
than what was in the database.
OK, so you actually generate
a small model immediately.
A smaller model immediately,
even without any size penalty.
So your intuition
that a bigger model
was going to be better actually
turns out to be incorrect.
That even without a size
penalty, the model strips down.
And why is that?
Why is that?
Let me make that
question number two.
Just to see who's still awake.
Why, in fitting this
hepatocyte data,
would a model that leaves out
a lot of stuff in the Ingenuity
database that's presumably
going on actually
fit the data better?
A smaller model fits better?
Why is that?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: This is a [INAUDIBLE].
Maybe the strength
of the attractions
aren't really taken
into account here?
And so the moving things
out, essentially means
that you're not sealing
everything in the [INAUDIBLE].
You're just taking one.
DOUG LAUFFENBURGER: Yeah.
That's essentially it.
I think you've casted it an
almost quantitative term,
but I think it's true
even in qualitative terms.
And one way to think
about it is-- let's
say I have an extra
arc or extra node.
OK.
I might capture some
more true positives.
I might actually
capture more of my data,
but I could actually now, gain
more complex with my data.
Because now I've put
in logic that, yes,
it captures this
measurement, but now maybe it
messes up these other two
or three measurements.
So you actually can
make your model worse
trying to capture some small
piece, that in fact, adversely
influences the effects on
the other measurements.
So you get you get false
positives, false negatives,
along with anything
and that's true.
And it just so happens that
in these kind of situations
those can outweigh.
Then of course, as you
increase the size penalty
you can drive your model to
be even smaller, fewer arcs,
and now that of course
does come at the expense
of not fitting the data better.
OK.
So where we decided that
the size penalty best lived
was where it was large enough
to ensure stripping down
of nonessential nodes and
arcs, but not large enough
to start compromising the
actual experimental fit.
OK.
And so that lived
someplace around there.
OK.
An important thing--
and this goes back
to the consensus model.
If you think about, quote,
model identification,
can you uniquely specify
one model a best fit model?
You really can't.
What's plotted here is
for any of the arcs that
would end up in a model.
Let's say we let's say we
numbered them from one to I
think it was 113
in the first place.
One arc, another arc,
another arc, another arc.
And you say, how
frequently did they
end up in the best fit models?
Basically, only a small
proportion of them
were in all the best fit models.
Some of them were in
some models and some not.
Of course the higher
the tolerance,
the more air you
allowed and now you
started to get
models that all fit
to within whatever that criteria
was in which most of their arcs
weren't the same.
You could have a lot of
different network structures
that give you that same fit.
If you require a very, very
tiny fit, compared to air,
something like this, then
more of the arcs in the models
have to be in common.
OK.
So that makes some sense.
But you can't really completely
identify a unique model.
That goes to what I said before.
OK.
I was talking before
about trade-offs
between false positives
and false negatives.
You must know, I'm sure from
previous things in this class,
the receiver operating
characteristic curves,
where for every of your
model parameter choices,
you say, what are
my results in terms
of false positives
versus true positives?
And you're trying to
find the optimal location
along this type of path.
And so, what's shown here is
that the best predictive model,
in fact, is the one where
we have the size penalty
to be right on the edge of not
making the experimental data
fit worse, but still
strips out the most arcs.
So again, that demonstrates
that the smaller model actually
is in fact better, in terms
of finding this type of--
And this shows if we actually
put in some more arcs that
tried to capture some
more data, yes we decrease
the false negatives,
but, in fact, we
increase the false positives.
We actually shift
ourselves on this curve.
And so you decide whether
that's desirable or not.
Where you'd like to live.
So you can analyze what you
like about your best fit class
of models in this kind of way.
OK, so now we have some
confidence in this.
What are you going
to do with it?
And one thing I'd like to do is
just make a priori predictions.
Say I now believe that on
these hepatocytes or tumor
cells stimulated with
these kind of things,
I can calculate what the
experimental signaling
activities should be.
All right.
Let's see if we
do that a priori.
So let's now use new inhibitors
that hadn't been used before.
Combination of inhibitors,
especially in cancer.
People are always interested
in combinatorial drugs.
Experimentally it's
prohibitive to run
through all possible
combinations.
So this is one thing in
the pharmaceutical field
people believe these kind of
models are really useful for.
Let's try all possible
drug combinations
and see which ones
are most promising.
And instead of just one
ligand growth factor cytokine
at a time, do
different combinations.
So this is all an
entirely new data set.
So different treatments that
are different combinations,
different inhibitors, different
combinations of inhibitors.
And now you just run the model--
it's not trained on this.
It was trained on
the previous data.
And now a priori
predicts this data set.
And now, again, you look for
the model fit in the bottom.
And again, you want the smallest
number of red and pink boxes.
In effect it predicted to
within about 11% error.
About 11% of the boxes didn't
fit well, but 89% percent did.
And that's, in fact
pretty close to the 9%
that was on the
original training model.
So in terms of this, in
this realm of studies,
these a priori treatment
conditions-- drug combinations,
growth factors,
cytokine combinations--
this is a pretty good validation
that this model wasn't
just kind of trained and fit.
That it, in fact,
could predict then
what was happening
in these pathways.
And then of course, what
it allows you to do,
where all the red
boxes are-- it say, OK,
that's where we need
more intensive study.
Now maybe we go back to
the literature and say,
is there more known
about those nodes that
was captured in whatever
our interactive database
that we started with?
Maybe we need to supplement the
scaffold with more information.
That's out in the literature
where more and more dedicated
experiments are done.
So it narrows down where the
next set of investigations
need to be, whether from the
literature or from yourself.
OK.
So this is just then
some biological results.
If you do this for the four
different hepatocellular lines.
Some of the signaling
activities are the same,
and some are different.
I think I'll skip that.
All right, let me show this.
So this says, where are the
similarities and differences
between the normal hepatocytes
versus the tumor lines.
Because this is
where you would want
to get the ideas for where
the right drugs would be.
Where is the logic different,
between a normal liver
cell and one of these
transformed types.
So, this is the same
kind of scaffold.
It'll get us the
consensus models
and the thickness of
the line is how strong--
what proportion of the models
did that arc show up in?
Along the best.
If it's black, the arc was
in the primary hepatocytes
and all the cell lines.
So black is just sort
of consensus core.
This is just invariably there.
The blue was in the models
for the primary hepatocytes,
but for some reason didn't
exist in the tumor cell lines.
So we're signaling logic
that normal hepatocytes use,
that the tumor cell
lines have somehow lost.
Red, are arcs that weren't
in the primary cells,
but showed up in the
tumor cell lines.
So was logic that the normal
liver cells apparently
didn't use, but now showed
up in the tumor cell lines.
And why would there
be these differences?
Well this is where it goes back
to then the genetic mutations
and variations.
Because going from a primary
to some tumor cell line,
there's enough of the genetic
mutations, that in this case
said, OK, I've got some genetic
mutation that interrupts
the link between map
three kinase and Ikk.
There was some docking
protein or something
that's now missing, not
expressed as highly.
It's got a mutation
of amino acids
and no longer docks right.
It has a lower
enzymatic activity.
So now you can go
back and trace.
Can I find some
genetic mutation that
has to do with the
loss of that arc?
Or if I've got a red
arc that shows up--
like I said because
there was something
in my genetic mutations that
now adds an activity here
that wasn't there.
Maybe something is now
constituently active.
Maybe something is just
expressed at a higher level.
And all of a sudden that
pathway comes into play.
So that's the cool thing.
You can trace what's actually
in the genetic mutations
if you have some
methodology for that,
to what's actually been
altered in the network logic.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Are the primary
lines considered healthy lines?
Or are they--
DOUG LAUFFENBURGER: Yes.
AUDIENCE: OK, so the--
DOUG LAUFFENBURGER: Yeah.
So they're from
donors but they're
mainly like motorcycle accident
donors that don't either
liver anymore but
the liver was fine.
So, yeah, they're
from healthy donors.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
DOUG LAUFFENBURGER: Yeah.
Yeah.
It was the lines at some
point came from a tumor
and have been propagated
in a culture, yeah.
OK.
What do I want to-- got
a little bit more time.
Let me do this.
OK.
So here's another interesting
thing that can happen.
If you take these
models seriously,
it can tell you something
about the biochemistry, perhaps
of what's going on.
So see there's this dashed line
here that I want to emphasize
and we'll emphasize it
again on another slide.
That was one that
had to be added.
It just wasn't in the
Ingenuity pathway, scaffold.
Actually couldn't find it
in any literature anywhere.
But nonetheless you needed
it to fit some data.
So we kind of kept
our eye on that one.
What the heck is going on here?
This dashed line from I kappa
kinase up to step three.
No evidence for that signaling
linkage in the literature
anywhere.
What could that tell you?
All right.
Well, you go back to the
data now and you say,
well what of the data set, of
the experimental measurements
that we made, caused
that arc to have
to be there to
fit the data well?
OK.
You can now ask that
kind of question.
Well remember I said in the
data set were inhibitors.
Some small molecule
inhibitors against this kinase
or that kinase or that kinase
that would perturb the network
and then give us relationships
at the logic model
and had to account for.
Well, this one had
to be there, mainly
to account for data that came
from an inhibitor of Ikk.
That one of the kinases
that we had a small molecule
inhibitor for,
inhabited this kinase.
And somehow there
turned out to be
an effect on staph
3 phosphorylation.
And so you needed
that arc to be there.
So either the explanation
that either there's,
in fact, some real
mechanism going on here.
It might have been
transcriptional
that somehow the
activity of this kinase
affects the levels of expression
and the responsiveness
of staph 3.
Or you say, ah, maybe it's
a problem with the drug?
It's a problem
with the inhibitor.
That, in fact, what you thought
was an inhibitor that just
affected this kinase, has
an off-target target effect
on that kind of that kinase.
And it's just an artifact.
That's an alternative
explanation.
Right, so that's the sort
of thing you can test.
And we did test it.
And here's the data here.
At the bottom is the kinase that
you wanted the inhibition 2.
And in the blue was the
inhibitor that was actually
used in the study, both
in vivo and en vitro
and it inhibited that kinase.
But then we looked at the
potential off target effect
on that other-- the
JAK2 [? stat ?] 3
and it also did have
activity on that.
So it meant that
that inhibitor had
an effect, not just on the Ikk,
but also on the JAK [? stat ?]
3.
And so that's why that
arc had to be there,
is because, in fact,
that inhibitor,
inhibited this kinase as well.
So if we took that into account
in terms of the algorithm,
then we wouldn't have to
have that arc because it
was spurious and came
from the arc, in fact,
of that inhibitor.
But the interesting thing
is that, by taking the model
seriously, we can
actually find that.
Because it was not previously
known that this inhibitor had
an off-target effect
on that kinase.
In effect, the interesting
thing, pharmacologically,
was that this
small molecule that
was aimed to be an inhibitor
against this kinase
was the best by far in treating
lung airway inflammation,
compared against
a whole other set
of other types of inhibitors
for the same kinase.
So now the reason
might be is, it's
better because it's also
hitting this other kinase.
That this off-target
effect actually
is therapeutically
efficacious and in fact
a combination of drugs
against this kinase
and the other kinase
is what's required
for the therapeutic benefit.
So that's something
that could be explored.
And that's the sort of
thing this model leads to.
OK.
Let me end by digging into
this difference a little bit.
Because I said, you
see these differences
between primary hepatocytes
and the tumor cell lines.
And the model said, just
from examining the data sets,
that the logic is different.
OK.
Is there any
validation for that?
Well, so let's go back and
look at those differences
with respect to literature.
So if you just blow up
that part of the model,
there's eight edges
that are strongly
disparate between the primary,
normal cell types and the tumor
cells and they're
all enumerated here.
One, two, three, four,
five, six, seven, eight.
And they're essentially in
three different pathways.
So what the model
is telling you is
that there's three different
pathways that are substantially
different between a normal liver
cell and a liver tumor cell.
OK.
So is there any evidence
that this is really true?
So let's look at one.
On to this pathway that
I've got differences.
And you see blue
here and red here.
It says that this particular
signaling node in normal cells
is activated by this pathway.
In the tumors, that
regulation is lost
and that actually comes
through another pathway.
And it turns this is
consistent with literature
that, in fact, in
the tumor cells,
you get a higher activity
of this downstream node.
And now I've lost
my light again.
This HSP27.
Even though it's
over expressed, you
get less activation because
this pathway is less strongly
activated in red than
the blue pathway is.
So if you went by
gene expression,
you'd think in the
tumor cells, this
is a higher activated pathway.
Turns out the
logic is different,
and you actually get
less activation of it
because it's coming from
a different pathway.
So that turns out to be true
in the liver tumor literature.
Another one-- I find this
one really interesting.
That in normal liver cells,
to activate this Ikk pathway--
that's a very important
kinase pathway,
governing the transcription
factor of NF Kappa b.
In a primary cell, I
need this combined logic
between a pathway downstream
of insulin receptor
and a pathway downstream
of a cytokine.
Only if both of those pathways
are on, do I now turn this on.
In the tumor cells,
that check is lost.
Only one pathway is required.
OK.
If this one is
activated, I'm going
to get this transcription
factor activated.
I don't have to wait for
simultaneous activation
of this pathway.
Where as a normal
says I have to.
OK.
That turns out to be true
that in the liver cells,
the progression is
associated with a looser
regulation of this
transcription factor.
And one more.
I won't go into too much
detail, but again, you
see reds and blues here.
In the tumor cell
lines, you've now
got activities
downstream of insulin.
That's normally just
a survival factor,
that's just not found
in the primary cells.
And that, in fact, is shown
in the literature too,
that insulin signaling
shifts from metabolism
to proliferation.
It's mainly metabolic, stimulus.
In the normal cells it turns
into a proliferative stimulus
in the tumor cells.
OK.
So, what this says is,
just by mapping this logic
scaffold, the scaffold
against empirical data,
developing a logic
model, you in fact
can find loci of differences
between the normal cell
signaling logic and tumor
cells signalling logic
for which there's evidence in
the literature, none of which
was in the original databases.
Finally, I'm going
I'm just going
to say that it turns out in
another study, what you could
show is those three pathways
that the model predicts
are the differences
between the liver tumor
cells and the normal cells.
That in order to kill
these liver tumor cells,
you need inhibitors against all
three pathways simultaneously.
You actually need
combination drugs
of three different pathway
inhibitors to kill these cells.
And it's exactly
the three pathways
that the model predicted of the
differences between the normals
and the tumor cells.
OK.
All right, so I will
end here and then see
if there's any more questions.
Something that
comes up a lot is--
there's discomfort with Boolean
logic because of zero, one.
It's off, on, and of
course we know biology,
biochemistry doesn't
work that way.
And so there can be
so many artifacts,
so many places that you
can get things wrong,
because you're trying to fit a
model where the measurement is
supposed to be
either zero or one,
and you're comparing it
against a measurement that
might be 0.6.
Well, 0.6, is that closer
to 1, is it closer to 0?
Is there some normalization
that would shift it
from one to the other.
And instead of being a correct
fit, it's now an incorrect fit.
So you can see the
room for artifacts
by mapping quantitative data
against a qualitative model.
So, one thing done more
recently is to admit that
and say, well, let's say
just relax this a bit.
And instead of having step
functions from off to on,
that they're more graded.
It's like an analog
transfer function.
So what you've essentially
done is add one more parameter
to every node, to every gate.
Because of Boolean
logic, there's
essentially one
hidden parameter.
That's where you shift
from off to on, right?
There's some location of
the level of the signal
that you've decided is 0 or 1.
So there's some parameter
that you shift from,
saying it's off to on.
Well here now in this
formalism there's that,
but there's also then the slope
of shifting from off to on.
Is it still fairly steep?
Is it really mild?
Is it someplace in between?
OK?
And this can go with
AND and OR gates too.
Now, instead of
just one dimension,
one component being
off to on or on to off,
now you got AND and OR gates
that have these slopes as well.
So what this means is
you require more data
to fit this-- we call it a
constrained fuzzy logic model
because you've got-- if I've
got 50 nodes in my system,
I've got 50 more
parameters I've got to fit.
OK, so that requires more data.
What's the benefit of it, is
that your predictions now,
in fact, can be quantitative.
So you can go into
the model and say
here's a transcription
factor CREB.
I'm going to predict its
phosphorylation state
and its transcriptional
activity, perhaps,
based on the activities
of two upstream kinases.
And so if I had had an inhibitor
for one of these kinases
or another, how much would
I shift the phosphorylation
of this transcription factor?
And what you actually see is
these gradual curves, that if I
start to inhibit
[INAUDIBLE], OK, it gradually
changes the
phosphorylation of CREB.
Or if I inhibit the
activity of P38,
it even more gradually
effects the activity of CREB.
So you can turn these into
quantitative predictions
of strong effects, weak effects.
And again, look at
drug combinations.
So that's the advantage of going
to this more analog transfer
function logic model.
You can deal with
quantification much better,
but at the cost of
requiring more data.
OK, I think I'll leave it here.
It's about 3:15
and so if there's
more questions we can take
them about any aspect of this.
Most of you have stayed awake,
I think that's a good thing.
OK.
More questions?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
When you have the model for
the template of the Ikk story.
And then it seems
like it may not
be as easy to back out
the original data that
led to that specific mode.
For example, you
showed that one arc
was from this one treatment.
But because if you trained
the model the same as that
and it's not deterministic,
then what-- could you just add--
DOUG LAUFFENBURGER: I think
that's a great question.
So let's say there's
new arcs that you add,
that weren't in the
original scaffold.
I mean that's what you got
the biggest questions from.
If you delete one,
you say, ah, it's
easy to believe why
you would delete one.
Any arc that you add
to get a best fit,
I think you've got to
ask questions about.
So in all those
cases where there
are arcs that were added that
led to a better fit model,
the first thing we did
was go to the literature.
Say, OK, is there literature
on some affect of this node
to that node?
And it's just that
that literature
wasn't curated
into that database
or something like that.
And most of the time
we could find it there.
OK.
So then there were the cases,
and this was the most prominent
one, where from some
added arc, we just
couldn't find it
in the literature.
In this particular
case, it was very
easy to trace it to
this particular effect
of this inhibitor.
I would say there's no reason
to believe that that's always
going to be the case.
I don't have another example to
show you where it was harder.
Everything else we actually
found in the literature.
But you could imagine, having
some new arc that you really
couldn't find in the
literature and there's
no artifactual
explanation for it.
And now, how you trace it
back to what the data was
that might give you
a more nuanced hint.
It's a great question.
I don't really know
how we'll do that.
I think, we and other
practitioners who use this,
I'm sure we'll run
into it at some point.
That's a great challenge
to be thinking about.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I might have
missed this earlier,
but I was wondering,
is this model actually
able to incorporate the
heterogeneity of a tumor,
for example?
Or the population heterogeneity?
DOUG LAUFFENBURGER: That's also
a really interesting question.
Let me try to show
something here.
Yeah.
So two things.
One is, what's shown here--
this is the four different tumor
cells that we did.
And what's shown in color is
the arcs for each one of them.
So yellow, orange, brown, red.
So some places you see all
four of those colors there.
In some places only two or one.
It says if I had four
different tumor types,
there's some slight differences
in logic among them.
You could translate
to that is, well
I could imagine
then having a tumor
that's a mixture of sub types
and how would I discern that?
One possible idea that's
attractive to me--
although we didn't really
explore this in any form of
[INAUDIBLE].
We didn't really have
the means to make
experimental
measurements on the tumor
heterogeneity at the time.
It's when you get to a
set of consensus models.
Right.
So let's say you get the 50
best fit models and you say,
some arc is in 80% of them,
but it's not in 20% of them,
is it possible that
that represents
some of heterogeneity
because you're
getting an average of
different subtypes?
I don't know.
Sometimes that appeals to
me as potentially valid.
Sometimes I think there's
a flaw in that reasoning.
Just because you get an average
that's not then as strong.
Does that necessarily
reflect a sub-population?
I don't know.
So what we do know is,
we can see differences
when there are differences.
How you actually see
them then, if all you
have is averaged
data, maybe it's
reflected in the heterogeneity
of the consensus models.
Maybe not.
It would be an
interesting to explore.
Anybody else?
All right.
All set.
Thanks.